marseillais ont démontré une farouche
volonté de s'imposer la preuve que
l'olympique de marseille ne sera jamais
un club tout à fait comme les en france
marseille fait figure d'exception dans
aucune autre ville le club de foot local
ne suscite autant de commentaires de
polémiques d'engouement
et quand même beaucoup d'eau et de
chaleur de ferveur justement qu'un match
ça va être le plus le mât d'après est
extrêmement hâte et le maire qui n'a
jamais rêvé de fouler la pelouse du
stade vélodrome où j'étais petit je
rêvais de l'om comme vous parlez ghana
maintenant de notre région
qui n'a jamais rêvé de jouer au sein de
cette équipe mythique sous les
acclamations de toute une ville de 3 ans
sondages il y avait 10 millions de
sympathisants pour le club en france
c'est pour ça que marseille n'est pas un
club comme les autres pour une poignée
de jeunes ce rêve peut devenir réalité
ils évoluent tous au sein de l'équipe
réserve de l'om ici à marseille pour les
appelle les minots de l'om
allez
faut égaliser
pour aller
légaliser
aulas
il faut égaliser faut y aller
c'est la saison 2009-2010 qui débute au
centre d'entraînement de l'om les
supporters sont déjà présents au défilé
des voitures de luxe qui annonce la
rentrée de cette nouvelle équipe
dix sept ans que marseille n'a pas
remporté le moindre titre alors comme
chaque année ils se disent que cette
fois ce sera la bonne mais c'est aussi
le début du championnat pour l'équipe
réserve
la petite soeur de l'équipe première ce
sont ces deux destinées parallèles que
nous allons suivre durant toute cette
saison
essentiellement composée de jeunes
joueurs issus du centre de formation
l'équipe réserve est le vivier de l'om
le sas entre la formation et le monde
pro pour la plupart des clubs de foot
la priorité est désormais mise sur la
formation afin de faire émerger le plus
de jeunes possible sur le marché
professionnel vous avez la possibilité
de prendre trois quatre joueurs de très
haut niveau que vous payez cher mais
cela va nous apporter quelque chose
palpable très vite mais après vous avez
le 15e le 16e le 17e que vous payer au
prix fort et que vous pouvez former et
qui peuvent rentrer doucement dans une
équipe professionnelle
d'abord pour être un complément
d'effectif et puis par la suite devenir
des titulaires et c'est ce qu'il faut
faire avec le ca de formation jusqu'au
jour vous avez des pépites comme nasri
ou là quand vous les sortez ça fait
votre bonheur pendant deux trois ans et
vous les vendez ça mais à l'équilibré
financier un club pendant deux trois ans
même si l'équipe réserve n'est pas
constituée de joueurs pros elle a prouvé
qu'elle pouvait remplacer sa grande
soeur l'om et être la digne
représentante de la ville à marseille
personne n'a oublié que l'équipe des
minots doit son nom à une génération
inscrits dans la légende
l'om c'est fini l'olympique de marseille
a été déclaré ce matin en cessation de
paiement par le tribunal de commerce
était en 1980
l'équipe de l'om était alors au plus mal
et devait affronter le pire
la liquidation du club 180 était bien
celle du nord-ouest à l'époque ne pas se
rendre compte aujourd'hui mais c'était
c'était un drame à marseille le
personnel et les joueurs furent mises au
chômage technique il ne restait plus
grand monde pour tenir la baraque et
coûte que coûte ne pas mettre
définitivement la clé sous la porte
et finalement on a trouvé ce qu'ils
étaient les moins payés c'est à dire
nous que des jeunes et six matches sans
perspective d'avenir
les gros salaires pour laisser la place
à des gamins opérante 3e division
rappelez vous ils avaient pour nom
kamini qui les vit anigo guy mais qu une
structure provisoire est mis en place et
on se rend à l'évidence que pour finir
la saison le club devra aligner l'équipe
réserve
une équipe qui n'a jamais joué un seul
match pro est venu me chercher
yuuwaa ils veulent rencontrer etc
je demande pourquoi c'est pour entraîner
un cadre et une équipe s'arrête
entraîneur à 27 ans n'est pas trop jeune
je sais pas si ces projets mais c'est
c'est assez exceptionnel je pense et ce
que personne n'aurait pu prévoir c'est
que durant les six derniers matches de
la saison
ces minots d'aller posséder aucune
défaite face aux équipes
professionnelles un conte d'aniane
d'avril le club sortait alors la tête de
l'eau et pouvait reprendre à nouveau une
nouvelle saison pour des jeunes qui tous
réunis devait toucher dix mille frei à
tous en série golo comme quoi l'argent
il fait pas tout la vie la passion et ça
c'est marseille y'a qu'à marseille qu'on
voit ça leur persévérance allaient être
récompensés en 84 l'om remonte est un or
en première division après quatre années
de purgatoire
c'était une équipe de copains qui a
malgré tout sauver ce club là parce
qu'il faut savoir à l'époque que si
cette équipe là avait sombré
peut-être que le club aurait disparu on
l'a vécu des moments que je souhaite à
tous les joueurs de football parce que
c'était c'était assez unique en termes
de dinde de passions qu'on avait tous
pour ce club et de bonheur qu'on avait à
vivre ensemble
moi je vraiment j'ai vécu de belles
années avec c'est avec ce groupe là avec
son ailier anigo redonne à santos qui
crochète vers le centre attend la sortie
le rosier du gauche le premier but
pour cette nouvelle génération de
minaucourt ans à la sab le mans sous lé
regard bleuté des légendes de l'om on en
vient à rêver on se dit que cette saison
on va tout donner
que rien ne peut nous arrêter et que les
portes du monde pro vont bien finir par
s'entrouvrir
vous aviez pas tout si ce dernier
entraînement avant notre match de samedi
donc le rendez-vous à 4h30
16h45 j'espère comme miroir peut lire
tout comme l'équipe première la réserve
se prépare à disputer son championnat
elle évolue actuellement cfa2 et l'enjeu
collectif de cette année et d'une montée
en division supérieure en cfa
malheureusement notre réserve et en cfa2
et non pas ancefa donc le niveau est
quand même un fossé important entre le
cfa 2 et la ligue 1 et encore plus avec
marseille et ses exigences
donc là c'est sur un plan purement
sportif mais après il faut qu' il puisse
aussi gagnant en maturité
c'est un long parcours du combattant
mais il faut pas que des qualités
footballistiques
il faut aussi un état d'esprit un mental
on en est à notre quatrième journée en
ajout la 4e journée donc on va jouer la
cinquième
on est un peu le début de l'objectif
c'est de se préparer de la meilleure des
façons pour le match à riom
on se prépare bien pour tous les matchs
on prépara bien donc que tous les
joueurs soient mieux préparés pour
devenir de foudras professionnels qui
est le but suprême
la plupart de ces joueurs a été recruté
par le centre de formation dès l'âge de
13 14 ans ils ont dû gravir les marches
une à une pour accéder à l'équipe
réserve ils ont à présent deux en deux
ans pour signer pro ou bien quitter le
club
deux ans pour franchir les 100 mètres
qui les séparent de l'équipe première
malheureusement sur une génération de
joueurs
seule une minorité pourra gagner sa vie
de sa passion un groupe jeune
cette année ou l'année dernière on
faisait plutôt mixte avec des joueurs
pris la plus âgée il ya de la qualité
mais j'espère au cannet le maximum qui
arrivent mais sur un groupe comme ça si
on dit allez y en a un ou deux ce serait
vraiment une super donc
donc il ya du travail et du travail on
est là pour ça l'est
dans cette équipe
chacun est à une étape différente dans
sa progression vers le monde
professionnel
il y à nico le croate qui est en
première année
olivier le rescapé qui revient sur le
terrain après un an et demi de blessure
sénat le togolais qui a été repéré par
les pros mais qui est bloqué pour un
problème de licence
alexander qui suit régulièrement les
entraînements avec l'équipe une
jordan qui a déjà eu le privilège de
signer un contrat avec le club mais
qu'il n'a pas encore disputé de match
officiel en ligue 1 et enfin il y a à m
le grand frère ça lui fait plaisir du
mois c'est à madhuri donc né le 8 avril
1979 je précisais à des messages parce
que par rapport à mes collègues sont nés
en 98 91
je suis plus âgé de l'effectif je suis
venu à l'om l'ac et l'inter ma troisième
année je suis venu un peu loin pour
venir un peu essayer d'encadrer ces
jeunes là 2
de pouvoir les peut les conseiller leur
montrait un peu bon exemple je suis un
peu un peu comme un grand frère pourquoi
tout incident signalé
on parle de zidane
et si je peux leur donner un millième de
ce qu'ils apprennent équipe à peuvent
leur permettre de d'en faire leur métier
moi s'il ya environ devant la télé voilà
moi si c'est ma satisfaction c'est vrai
la plupart des jeunes qui sont
infertiles de cfa 2 cette année c'est
l'année de jeu dirait de transition de
transition de manière c'est un peu le
bac de leur formation de footballeurs
l'installer c'est un peu leur bac c'est
à dire soit ils ont ils ont leur bac qui
correspond au contrat pro et soit ils
n'ont pas généralement et bon sens
obligé de pratiquement 2 0
triés sur le volet dès leur plus jeune
âge pour certains il a fallu quitter
famille pays cultures et affronter seul
à nouvel environnement
senna a été repéré au togo il a quitté
son pays à l'âge de 13 ans s'est dit si
des gens déjà quant à lui m'ont contacté
j'étais si j'étais content de vina nord
parce que tout le monde mais finalement
on fait jouer j'étais content est le
jouet je suis monté dans l'avion
elle est là on commence à couler et ça
reprend pourquoi et j'arrive franchise
arriver parce que je ne crois s'est
crashé en vie je ne connaissais personne
personne
j'étais timide s'est dit si dumas
prochain au collège mais si le thème
bien son ballon rond combat ça pas aller
tu vois et séparatistes conseil
islamique et la vie de senna est partagé
entre le terrain de foot et l'internât
du club cette masse ty accueille les
jeunes joueurs éloignés de leur famille
c'est ici qu'il reconstruise des liens
affectifs grâce à toute l'équipe
pédagogique qui les entoure j'attends
mes 18 ans pour prendre la porte
je crois en la baptisant comme d'hab la
rejeter ça fait dj set c'est quelque
chose quoi c'est comme chez moi là bas
si c'est chez moi je suis habitué avec
ça fait quatre ans que je suis là donc
ça crée des liens après qu'elle tu vois
partir tu avais plein open kata chez
nous
bonjour chose et voilà l'essentiel
comment ici les chambres sont sur deux
étages comme une pyramide des nouveaux
venus au plus confirmé les espoirs de
l'om étant au sommet du bâtiment alors
que les autres partagent leurs chambres
à plusieurs
les privilégiés du dernier étage sont
seuls tout comme nasri flamini et à la
place des états sénat qui va bientôt
avoir 18 ans vit ses derniers moments à
l'internât
mais après tous mes collègues vont me
manquer quand même parce que j'ai
l'habitude avec eux quand j'y viens
j'aimerais servir gueule avec eux par
les requins et discuter ce que ce qu'on
a fait de la gironde bientôt rien dit
que s'il prenait la part de syrie située
sur israël mais c'est obligé de faire
avec ça fait partie de la vie dans la
forêt face c'est clair qu'il par leur
manque
je vais pas remplacer leur père c'est
clair mais fait je le gère le centre un
bon père de famille j'ai seulement
reproché et à l'affection j'ai deux
enfants aussi donc un jeu c'est un peu
ce que si il se confie facilement mangé
du chameau qui se libèrent et j'ai
quarante jeunes qui veulent déménager
comment je fais
je fais les équipements trop vétuste
éloignés du centre de formation c'est la
fin de carrière pour cette bastide
soucieux d'améliorer la qualité des
infrastructures
le nouvel internat sera au coeur même du
centre d'entraînement à la commanderie
en ce début de saison les choses ne se
présentent pas très bien pour l'équipe
réserve elle joue aujourd'hui sa
huitième journée de championnat contre
monaco
elle n'obtiendra qu'un match nul
elle est désormais 6e au classement sur
les seize équipes de son groupe pour
trouver ses jeunes perles le club
prospecte dans le monde entier nico a
été recruté en croatie comme pour senna
l'expatriation a été difficile première
des années c'était plus facile mais
après que j'ai découvert un peu ce monde
là c'est ça devient dur parce qu'après
il ya des choses qui commençait à me
manquer mes parents tout d'abord ma
famille et les sorties avec mes
collègues mon équipe de là bas la
mentalité ma ville agréable moment trop
c je regrette pas du tout pas du tout
c'est vrai que ça me manque mais c'est
des sacrifices qu'il faut faire pour
réussir des sacrifices il y en a
beaucoup
hygiène de vie repas équilibrés peu de
sorties pas d'alcool
bref pas vraiment une vie d'adolescent
comme les autres mais si la passion est
là ces efforts représente bien peu face
aux difficultés à surmonter la plus
grosse difficulté c'était la langue
parce que je parlais pas français quand
j'arrive ici forcément c'est une
barrière pour moi et après une fois
qu'un cas j'ai appris la langue de
goethe est acceptée mieux qu'au début
mais au début j'étais vraiment seul
quand j'étais chez moi et mes problèmes
tout ça est la dernière j'ai eu mon bac
avec la mention assez bien donc
oui exact le prochain défi de nico c'est
de signer pro avant la fin de son
contrat de stagiaire dans deux ans
la plupart de ces joueurs ont leur bac
un bagage indispensable lorsque l'on
sait que sur une génération seulement
deux ou trois jeunes feront une carrière
professionnelle j'ai pas voulu me criant
il ne lâche pas pour aux côtés des
études l'achat fort ses mystères et la
tête ou est fort va-t-on barde par
lâcher parce que le foot est ce parce
qu'il sera enterré servait il joue aussi
donneur fois passé mon bac j'ai eu
aujourd'hui c'est une journée
particulière même si l'objectif de tout
c'est de réussir le championnat
individuellement il s'agit surtout de se
faire remarquer par le staff des pros et
ils sont tous là didier deschamps josé
anigo liste efforts des pros par
conséquent la commission pas trop
l'occasion de les bourrer joue aussi les
jeunes c'est un bon moyen de se font
remarquer pourquoi de d'avoir déjà au
moins une appréciation
c'est pour ça qu'on est un peu plus
engagement aujourd'hui que je vais
rendre encore plus c'est lors de ces
matchs d'entraînement que l'om repères
ses futurs joueurs professionnels il y a
un an c'est à l'occasion d'une de ces
rencontres que senna fut remarqué mais
un problème administratif à tout freiné
la fédération française de football lui
a retiré sa licence car selon le
règlement un joueur mineur ne peut se
voir délivrer de licence si ses parents
ne vivent pas sur le territoire français
son avocat a lancé une pétition pour
qu'il puisse jouer en attendant le 13
décembre le jour de ses 18 ans j'ai raté
des jouets j'ai envie de jouer
sans ça le foot et je me sens pas bien
je m'entraîne ici bas et bien bien sûr
je m'entraînais les masses en mémoire
donc
moi j'aimerais bien voir ma licence et
d'avoir autant plus si senna récupère sa
licence et si le club est toujours
intéressé alors il pourra participer de
nouveau aux entraînements avec les pros
il y en a quelques-uns qui ont construit
nous depuis deux trois ans qui viennent
et qui s'entraîne avec les pros qui
repartent avec la cfa on sent que il ya
encore un petit manque d'expérience il
encore ce qui est dû à laurent jusqu'à
l'envol mai et après c'est justement pas
cette période où ils viennent avec les
pros où tout se joue où tout se fait
donc pour nous les jeunes comme moi je
suis avec le prochain chaque
entraînement c'est ça être un gars une
bataille appelée si tout le monde mais
je dois me donner à fond
montrez à certaines choses au coach et à
aux joueurs donc qu'ils voient que j'ai
envie de jouer faux jumeaux n'a en fait
pas à chaque entraînement avec les pros
pour moi c'est une sorte de test en fait
alexander fait lui aussi partie des
espoirs de l'om ils évoluent en équipe
réserve mais participe régulièrement aux
entraînements de lier des champs
originaire du gabon
il est venu à l'âge de 11 ans vivre chez
son oncle à martigues
c'est dans ce club de foot qu'il a été
repéré par l'om que je gagne ma pas sur
le banc pourquoi pas être titulaire même
si c'est difficile mais un bon si jamais
vous savez ça va le foot pour moi c'est
inconcevable qu'un jeune qui vient avec
les pros traîne des pieds ou ne met pas
cette cette joie est pas le plaisir
d'être là je peux pardonner tout
purement sur le plan tactique technique
mais sur une envie la générosité ça
c'est voilà ici c'est la formule 1 là on
est encore dans les cartes
on est
on se prépare c'est pas le même circuit
et c'est pas le même moteur là il ya
tout qui est fait pour les mettre dans
le meilleur des conforts et non parce
que de pâtes de ce passage où il ya à
peu près 100 mètres de différence entre
la cfa ici ça se mérite et c'est pas qui
pour eux rien est acquis
jordan le sait très bien en signant son
tout premier contrat pro avec l'om il a
emboîté le pas de son grand frère andré
ayew autres joueurs du club
prêté cette saison à arles-avignon ils
sont tous les deux des fils d'abedi pelé
une des légendes de l'om avec qui il a
remporté la ligue des champions en 93
même si dans son cas
le foot est une histoire de famille sur
le terrain lui seul peut justifier sa
place chez les pros les naturelles pour
les mousses août dans ma famille tout le
monde j'aime et je vais deux frères qui
sont professionnels ça fait mon père qui
était ancien pro aussi
alors c'est sûr que nous les garçons
avaient tous suivent les traces à mon
père mais bon on va essayer de faire
comme mon père mais bon ça a été un peu
difficile
le père de jordan peut être fier de son
fils oubliez deschamps l'a sélectionné
en tant que remplaçant pour le prochain
match contre lorient il va partager le
banc avec ses idoles en espérant faire
sa première rentrée avec l'om
non mais j'ai déjà pris hier dans les
vestiaires après l'entraînement
l'univers - on à dié surpris j'étais
très content très plaisir alors que
jordan touche du doigt le rêve de tous
les résultats de l'équipe réserve sont
mitigés il reste un match avant la trêve
hivernale et l'équipe i 8e au classement
elle va devoir réagir au plus vite pour
obtenir sa montée en cfa senna quant à
lui attend avec impatience ses 18 ans
pour obtenir à nouveau sa licence
certains les traditions donc à revoir
celle en prie dieu je remercie mon dieu
de m'avoir gardé arbres santé
c'est d'intégrer le top du top
peut-être le banc pour enfin l'entrée de
15 minutes c'est pourquoi pas faire un
acteur décisif marqué un but et tout est
lynché mais ce qui pourrait m'arriver
debost année d'habitude c'est toujours
mon frère il est comme ça il est 22h
jusqu'à marseille
la séance vidéo là
je suis pas commencé j'ai jamais revoir
jordan doit faire face à une grosse
pression car pour l'om la prochaine
rencontre est capitale
éliminé de la champions league et 6e de
ligue 1 l'om doit se reprendre si elle
veut rester dans le groupe de tête du
championnat jordan avance serein vers
son destin en espérant faire sa première
apparition chez les pros et peut-être
exploser au grand jour
j'ai la larme à droite puis je voir jeep
ici à gauche mondiale mais dire
j'y tiens j'avais peur au début j'avais
peur
mais pour le dit bon je préparais tous
ses astra et tout ça avec eux
on m'a toujours dit que le foot aller
très vite mais là c'était vraiment
quelque chose de magnifique